( music playing )
- Hello there. I'm Gav.
- I'm Dan.
Welcome
to "The Super Slow Show."
- Gav, we're at the beach!
- We are at the beach.
We just swam in
from New Zealand.
- Just back there.
- Yeah, that's real,
that happened.
- Made it to shore.
- Yep, love swimming.
Love sunbathing,
making sandcastles.
You any good
at making sandcastles?
To be honest,
I've always been a sort of
one bucket of sand, call it a
day than dig a hole kinda guy.
- I'm pretty good.
- Have you got advanced
techniques
- for sandcastles?
- I do.
I reckon we should have a
sandcastle building competition.
Yeah, all right.
What's the slo-mo?
Well we don't have to,
you know,
smash anything,
blow anything up.
Oh, so you just want
like a nice,
friendly, civil video.
- Yeah.
- All right.
- Yeah?
- All right, I'll build
a sandcastle.
Here's your bucket.
- And, uh, have fun.
- All right.
- My bucket's a lot bigger
than yours.
- All right, here we go.
Sort of flatten out
an area here.
I think I need more wet sand.
That's a good start.
( whistling )
Okay, time is up.
Welcome to Chateau Dan.
- Ooh!
- Quite proud of this.
Check it out.
- Very nice.
- Here's my bedroom.
Oh, so you've got planned
where you live in it.
- This is yours.
- I never actually thought
a sandcastle was like
you can be miniature
and live in it.
What's the fun
otherwise, right?
I was gonna do a moat
but I ran out of time.
All right.
You wanna come
take a look at mine?
- Yeah.
- Just over here.
It's you and me
as mermen.
This one's you.
Why's he fat?
There's no way
you did this.
I don't think there's any
evidence I didn't do this.
There's no way
you did this.
You have no way of proving
that wasn't me who did this.
Right.
Well, that was an incredible
test of our sandcastle
building skills.
And I think the winner is clear.
Dan may have had some...
( Dan laughs )
You blew mine up,
didn't you?
No evidence of that
whatsoever. Nope.
You said, "Oh yeah we don't
have to blow everything up
in every video."
- You just blew mine up.
- You've got no proof.
- Yeah, blown up.
- No proof at all.
Gav:
It looks like a deranged
Mount Rushmore.
Dan:
Like if the person who made it
just got a bit drunk
- and knew what
they were doing.
- It looks like
if Mount Rushmore
was made of wax
and the sun was on it
for too long.
It's like
my first Mount Rushmore.
Both:
Oh!
Dan:
My jowls are gone!
It looks like his face
just got crushed.
Buggar!
Whoa!
That really did
get some height.
Gav:
It went about 20 feet I think.
It's just peppering the back
of my head at this point.
'Cause I turned around and saw
it and it was a huge explosion.
I was not expecting it
to be that big.
I think I held my ground
pretty well.
I didn't go down.
So, thanks for watching.
I hope you enjoyed that video
'cause I certainly did.
Make sure you subscribe.
And we'll see you
in the next episode
of "The Super Slow Show."
Oh, come on!
It's a crater!
( sighs )
- ( groans )
- ( laughs )
Gav:
Oh, man!
Dan:
Looks like someone dropped
a nuke on it.
Gav:
I like how it went out
of the bottom first.
Like it expanded and then
the top came out and then--
Dan:
It almost looks like
it's breathing at first.
Like it's taking a deep breath.
It's like...
Gav:
Under each sandcastle
we rigged up air motors
and set the PSI to 120.
Dan:
That's cool the effect
that the compressed air has
on like compacted wet sand.
Gav:
Do you like my "I've just
set off an explosion" pose?
Oh yeah, you're like...
God, there's so much
sand on me.
I wouldn't be able
to stand that.
I'd be like,
"Get it off me now."
Well, I think that was
a fantastic day out
at the beach, Dan.
- We could do a real house--
- So what happened there
was essentially
we said that we weren't gonna
make any explosions
and we were gonna have
a sandcastle building
competition, right?
All that happened was
that we blew up sandcastles.
- Yeah.
- Brilliant. Okay.
Gav:
Hopefully you enjoyed
being mislead.
Feel free to subscribe
to The Slow Mo Guys.
I'm gonna wash some sand
out my mouth.
And we'll see you
right back here on this channel
for the next episode
of "The Super Slow Show."
Do you think they fell
for the story?
- Do you think they believed it?
- I don't think anyone did.
- Don't think anyone bought it.
- ( Dan sighs )
( music playing )
- There was sumo wrestling.
- Magnet smash.
- The ice sculpture explosion.
- Fruit stand smash.
- Oh, that was really messy.
- Yeah, yeah.
I wonder,
what's your favorite?